It's the SuperDuper cut
He's on top of you carrying you open oh god, he's inside you hear yourself right accidental double entendre
I can't believe he's still alive. You believe that sir. What's dead boo - the super duper guy on hooray in digital
Oh, you dropped a super duper jumparoo scan your little toy PYP didn't you buddy?
Yes, I did.
Am so sorry I could never say no to the seafood platter at a gas station go
Oh, you're gonna need to power wash that where's Phil guess?
It's just you and me now don't skimp on the powder
Let's just get that whole undercarriage Deadpool - this SuperDuper cut now on blu-ray and Digital than a strong Trevor
in the beginning
You were nothingness
but then I filled you with adrenaline and laughter and a growing assortment of third tier Marvel characters, but suddenly
Our time together ended almost as soon as it began until
It didn't Deadpool number two the super duper cut now with 15 extra minutes
I know but it's all it's also notable
We gettin close
You all know the drill
Intercept the convoy
Watch out for cable
Hit it
There's this kid he's in trouble mover guy
Pump the hate breaks Thanos
Hey, let cable get to him I
Can't do this alone
Back up
We're gonna form a super duper fucking group. It's time to get back on LinkedIn
meets bettin luck
My name is chatter stark
Domino, I'm lucky
Luck isn't a superpower. It's certainly not very cinematic
Yes, it is let's meet in the middle and say no it is fucking It's Showtime, don't call it a comeback
No fucking hero, you're just a clown
Dressed up as a sex toy so darks. You sure you're not from the DC Universe
Bring it on one night, really
Whoo, yeah your bullets they're really fast
And last but not least Peter any powered want to tell us about no, I don't have one I just saw the ad
You're in
You